[Applause]
no early not exceed five companies
non-shooting foul instead now here's
Thompson from the other side head he
gets the three somebody got a motive and
Thompson hits the very difficult
schedule bikes 10 of 15 games against
part playoff teams and Thompson fires
hips problem on this one the timing was
perfect party late to get it to the
corner can't do that against Golden
Snitch this can also play point guard
with his spot well I guess he's doing it
right now if he ever wanted to because
of just ball handlers done
here's top cheston's for free.all he is
on fire time to look at this he's going
to lean forward and shoot it just not
good tap first round pick of the Mets
they d'el djem - the Lakers on traffic
the trade was kruseman and whooping 1
times once again famous Buster just his
team works I mean but you look at it
looked curried once Thompson is gone
this is the unselfish play seven four
seven
I'm wide open code should have shots
that he was behind it three-point line
there's top silicon propriety yes here
for full contact you played five on five
yesterday he wanted to play tonight but
the Lakers staff decided to wait until
at least Thursday to make them available
just more time to practice said you know
me it's just hard to be patient guys all
right
[Applause]